.IE TAYLOR GR ICOURT AND ON THE
DEFENDHED  FOREC ALE A
GROUP OF GEORGIA
THEY ACTIONS AD THE
h RIOT SHOULQUOLICUNDER , SHE DF
INSTE 2020 ELECTION.ARA WA FRON"
DAY IN C AS GETAE TAYLOREEK THEY
FROM RNG R
BEUSSHHAPLE JANUARY 6tIEPSTIIG
HAD LOST THE ELECTION TRUMP, CO-
OUTHOING TO MAKE NUTCAPITO MEAN
ARING ABOUT.VE NO IDEA WHA
TO JANUARh, 2021,
VEPLANE CAPITODING ILLO DI
THE PROC>> NO,BSOLUTELY
GREENSONABLE
OTHEAKERS.IDN'T TALK TO ANYBRNM
SPOKE TO REESGGOR STAFF ABOT FT
>> I DO NOREMEMBER.
>> Reporter: H A
REPRESENTATIVE COSAR?
>> SORRYI DON'T REMEMBER.
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS.SIA
>> DID YOU LIKE A POSTT ID, IT'R
TO REMOVNCY PELOSI FROM
THE -- IHAVE HAD MANY PE
MANAGE MY SOCIALIAOU
YEARS
WHO WRITES T ep3 FREQNT
JECTED TO THE TIINM YOANY AN
PIER IS RACE TIE>>ITICALFREE SPN
VIOLENCE.
ICS TO DESIBE TO AONRONEWSMAX
TO HAVE GO DOWN TOMORROW ON  WHD
JANUARY 6t
AND YO RESPONSWAS, TOMROW
>> I THEUR
>>REENE'S ATTORNEYS FOSI
ON HER OWN FEARST
>> WERE YOU AT THE ATTACK?
YESWA                  OUHAMBER
WHEN IT
>> SHED SOME WERE IO.
>> SNS, SOME
FINITEORE OF
THE CASEA PROVISION BARING
AMERICAN INDIVIDUALS FROM  IFOD.
PHE PRECEDR. IA CASE.orter: OUTO
ROLE'S IN THE INECRENGE
>> Reporter: I FT UMIN
IN 202NOW, THE JUDGE IO
KE DECISY NEXT MONTH
OR GREENE
DISQUALIFIED, HE WILL
RECOMMENDATION TO THE GEORGIA
SECRETARY OF S
INSURRECTION DISQUALIO IN THE 1T
FRHE.
THAT MEAN THIS IS PRION HA
MOD TERY.
ATLIN
LLR THE
CHALLENGER.
KATE.
>> THANK YOUER FOR THAT.G RIGH
ST
FLORIDA.
ODYOU.
>> THANK YOU.
TWIBATTLEAUSE NO ONE,
MARJORIECHARGED WITH A
JANUARY 6th.
THERE IS A RSOR THAT
DEF JUSTICE CONVENED
IT'SIEN OC YE S INT ON'TT ANO
CHARGERECTION.ES IER
HERE.
SOR TESTIMONY TODAY DNQU S PNN
ORDINATE
ARE OTTERS OARHE
FOUND TO BEY OF
THIS OFFENSE HERE IN THI
I TAO KOREA IT
BECAUSE AS WAS TRRORD URIKE  BE
RSONN LY T
BOUNCING A OF CONG C.TE TS.>> DG
ENT IN TT QUESON SPECULATION.
>> YOU'VE SAHAT, HAVEN'T YOU, M
>> NO, I HAVEN'T SAID
>> COULD YOU PLEASE ADVISE,
PLEASE.
>> OH, NO, WAIT, HOL NOW
E THAT UPHOLDINGURING
THE BORDER THAT THAT VIOLATES
FICE.LE HOW IT PLAYED OUT
ON THETA
DO Y TREENHE
OM THE B  THE AN IS ULTIMATELY
GETHE LIED THINK THROUT
YES, SHERT
HERS
UR KT SAYING
I DOSHE TALKED TO A
TA RJURY HE HURC ION.ACINUE TON
WILL CONTINUE TOOVHER.HED TO CKS
HESIT COULD
BELIEVE
EVS A CONSPIRACY AND S AR
F NANCY PELOSI
BACKTRACON COULD HURT R
STANS